it's time for would you rather live with
your host Daniel Tosh or would you
rather Dave Chappelle it's not gonna
happen one of my favorite games to play
in the workplace is would you rather but
after 10 seasons everyone on my staff
has agreed to fight their mom by now so
that's why I'm gonna play it with my
studio audience live reboot feel free to
play along at home too first audience
member are you from Alabama nice did you
go to the University of Alabama
well of course Oh roll tide I'm sorry
UCF we were undefeated we beat Auburn
who did you just lose to all right would
you rather never have any dessert or
never have any bread thank you that's
the way I react to that one
I guess dessert hey do you consider
candy a dessert no I don't eat it so you
can still have candy because I've never
been to a restaurant and under desserts
as I can
hello what's your name Cooper hey Cooper
would you rather take 17 years off your
life or be nine inches shorter
17 years off my life that's very cool
are you 6 1 is 6 1 - 9 inches would be 5
4 5 4 I'm not gonna argue with you what
is your name Angela thank you for
playing remember this is on television
so your answers are legally binding now
would you rather wrestle an alligator or
wrestle your dad naked wrestle my dad
naked
don't judge Angela don't judge Angela I
won't have it first of all could be a 1
foot alligator then your life I think if
you rub their bellies they fall asleep
what's him sir Jensen Jensen would you
rather eat every meal from 7-eleven or
only speak using an offensive
stereotypical Indian accent would you
rather get a nosebleed during every
lovemaking session or every Christmas an
extended family member gets murdered
which would you rather I would note the
nosebleed how much sex you have enough
yeah yeah sure what are you guys guys
know each other
your roommates next year am I supposed
to celebrate that
now work we're in college you know what
give that give that my I would rather
your friend
would you rather okay go deaf for three
years or share floss one time with a
homeless person who probably has AIDS I
mean I just brushed my teeth afterwards
like really fast right afterwards and he
would use his floss
I'd go with this philosophy I agree with
you because I said probably has AIDS so
that's not definitively we go and I
wouldn't floss like aggressive I
wouldn't be ramming it up there like
really I wouldn't you know you're
supposed to go on both sides and I
wouldn't do that I'm sure would you
rather get a throbbing erection
anytime you're near a child or scream
the n-word anytime someone says Barack
Obama
I'd rather go to commercial we'll be
right back with more Worlds
charities
[Applause]
you